now you will recall from yesterday that
when we looked at probability trees what
we map out is the chance of different
things happening so for example if we
were rolling a die rolling a day right
we know that we can describe all the
different outcomes that are there I
could for instance because there are six
possibilities six items in the sample
space for volleyer i could have six
branches going out but it depends very
much on what the question bless you on
what the question is asking you based on
whether you actually draw that many
branches or not so for example I might
decide to actually frame this a little
bit differently I might say what's the
probability of rolling a composite
number
now you haven't heard the word composite
number for a long time back in your
seven was the last time you met this
idea but here if you've got competent
numbers then you've got numbers that
aren't composite now let me do my G so
it helps you remember accomplish that
number is one that you can write as the
product of something times something
else and neither of those things is one
something times something else and
neither of those things is one okay so
for example two is not a composite
number because when you write that as
something times something what would you
write it as one times two is no other
way to write it you can't avoid writing
one right on the other hand six is a
composite number because you can write
it as 2 times 3 and you've avoided one
that's nice okay so how many composite
numbers are there on add I have a think
about it I've already told you one of
them there are two composite numbers
they are four and six okay that makes
all the other numbers excuse me at least
on a die not composite so one two three
and five that's really bad three okay so
now you can see the probabilities on
these branches are not the same
as opposed to if I just draw it out or
six they will all be 1/6 look when you
have a look at probably of each one
there are less favorable of edge here
then there are here to clear the chances
are different however favor events are
there here too
how many total those are there six so I
could easily write that as 1 over 3 okay
that would make this over here you could
come up one two three four and a six
which of course is 2/3 or you even could
have gotten to that number
2/3 without even counting what's another
way that we could have done it think
back to yesterday and I introduced this
idea we introduced value of a couple now
do you know a cup of it yeah I can
subtract this from one because I know
all of these items they're going to have
to all add up to 1 because that's every
possible event ok so we drew something
like this but then what I didn't get to
yesterday at least in terms of my
drawing is that sometimes the
probability tree continues right so I
might keep going like this so I might
roll a second die well maybe I'll draw a
card out of a deck or maybe I will bless
you maybe I will
maybe obviously maybe I'll flip a coin
right maybe I will select the student at
random so these events don't have to do
with each other they don't have to be
connected but they often are it's often
like I slipped two coins or I roll two
dice or something like that so again if
I do this right I could say composite or
not composite composite or not composite
right so I've got extra possibilities
that are kind of emerging as I do more
more events we call this a multi-stage
event it's got two stages to it and just
like before there's probabilities for
each of these I don't need to write two
fractions for each one I'm just going to
go straight to this simplified one so
we're going to go 1/3 2/3 1/3 2/3 okay
you notice in this case from one branch
to the next these probabilities are
identical you notice that why would they
be identical why don't they change like
for example is it it does it feel
natural to you that after rolling a
couples at number it's less likely to
roll it again no it's not because we
call these it is independent right they
don't have like this diet doesn't care
about this die they completely
disconnected it is actually true that
it's less likely to roll to concert
numbers but for a different reason that
I'm going to show you in a second over
on the right hand side I want you to
write see how I've got a first heading a
second heading right a third heading for
me which is sample space okay you can
see here each of these branches if I
follow them along they give me a
different kind of event right so the
first one the one right at the top here
and you've got a composite number on
this day and a composite number so so I
guess I could call that composite
composite right I then have the second
event which is composite not composite
and I can just keep on going down and I
can write all of them not composite
concert not composite hommerson
okay so there's a sample space and you
can see how the tree diagram helps you
create the sample space and make sure
you don't miss anything so now how do we
work out the probabilities to you how'd
it work out probably this one this one
and this one and this one any
suggestions for example what's the
probability how do I work out the
probability then I'll get two competent
numbers in a row any suggestions all the
numbers are there you just go choose how
to combine them you want to stick
the hand up and be back so this is a
little tricky things about probability
that we have a lot of instincts when it
comes to this and a lot of intuition but
the key with doing maths doing
probability mathematically is that you
do not need to rely on instinct even
though instincts will become important
in a second ash what's your suggestion
ok so I've had a suggestion of a quarter
I had a suggestion of that's going to be
a ninth are there any other suggestions
any other ways that I could combine this
could I suggest it seems like if I'm
interested in this top one to composit
numbers then I've got a confident
fraction here a constant fraction here I
could add them couldn't I like that's
another way of combining those fractions
so I've tried multiplying I can try
adding I can try I don't really know how
you got 1/4 but I could try that okay
actually I can't think of a way that you
get 1/4 out of this and that's not bad
I'm calling an editor where might have a
quarter come from this 1 2 3 4 so in 1
out of 4 ok so which one is it